hey youtubers awesome news whole bunch
of new Game of Thrones dropping the
casted interviews where they revealed a
bunch of details confirming theories
about season 7 and we got a new look at
Daenerys as dragonglass throne so just
careful for spoilers for everything
that's happened on the show so far
there's a new round of the HBO now
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber leave a comment on this
video so what's happened is is BuzzFeed
UK did a big interview with the cast and
crew they paired a bunch of people up
and they were just answering a bunch of
nonsense questions but when they asked
the actor to play euron greyjoy
who brightens his day the most when he's
on set with them he had to stop himself
because he almost gave away a spoiler oh
it's just about his boiler I was I was a
strong corrosive present know if you
didn't catch that he says I was about to
do a spoiler and then sort of covers his
mouth and laughs I was so close to
saying her name so it's a female
character it sounds like he's talking
about Cersei because early in the
trailer we see his ships riding up to
King's Landing with all the people
cheering so I don't really consider it
that much of a spoiler because we all
believe that you're on would at some
point be with Cersei whether that would
be on good terms or bad terms but we've
seen behind-the-scenes video that has
shown Cersei talking to one of the sand
snakes I won't say which one but it
sounds like you're on has a lot of
scenes with Cersei if they spent a lot
of time together on set in Lena Headey
was just making him laugh the whole time
and you're on going to be spending most
of the early episodes trying to take
down two nurses fleet but we know that
she makes it to Dragonstone relatively
early so it just moves the timeline of
Euron Cersei scenes way up in the season
but that doesn't necessarily confirm
that it's going to be the first episode
or the second episode but given that
there's only seven episodes plot is
moving so fast it just sounds like
you're on is going to be spending a lot
more time with Cersei than we thought
before because how much time could you
spend battling at sea like you have a
couple big battles one early in the
season where it sounds like he either
captures one or multiple sand snakes and
then later a big Greyjoy battle because
you see Theon you see Yara jumping from
ship to ship with everything blowing up
around them so that sounds like the
bigger battle that happens later in the
season so you're on and Cersei the enemy
of my enemy is my friend sound like
they'll make an alliance relatively
early in Euron could become one of
Circe's suitors which is just another
backdoor to drive a wedge between Cersei
and Jaime because he's one of the few
people that's not wearing the Queen's
Guard Armour even though he left the
Kingsguard last season you think that he
would change his armor in support of
Cersei but the way they tell story
visually with the costumes is very
important so they're just showing you
there is a team Cersei that Jaime is not
on not that you're on would suddenly
start wearing Queen's Guard armor - but
it's just another way to pair the two
most terrible characters on the show
together and when I say terrible I don't
mean bad characters I mean the most evil
characters even though TV show you're on
is a somewhat neuter version of book
you're on that's one of the biggest
complaints after last season in terms of
characters what happened to your on
Greyjoy he's so fantastically bad in the
books but here's the rest of that big
interview video the cast just talked
about some of the big beats of the
season this season is kind of about you
know the emerging rulers of kind of the
whole faerie preparing to kind of fight
to the spine in a way the Great Wall
there's a lot of meetups and everyone's
kind of it feels like the world is
getting much much smaller now every
farlis bath if we don't put aside our
animatics we will die when it doesn't
matter whose skeleton ships on the
eiffel rep is as bad as anything we've
ever had Lloyd King is on his way with a
hundred thousand of the old dead and
there isn't really there's no single
army as a defense gather the night
endure their time has come to join the
frame so the spectacle you know the
amount of spectacle that was ramped up
in season six with sequences like the
Battle of the bastards or happens or not
love the bastards cinematically if you
like going to have more the same in a
good way you want to give fans more of
what they've come to expect but enough
twist and complications in that event
never comfortable especially you get to
see them seven or so
you have to give them what they want I
was born to rule the Seven Kingdoms and
I will kind of the fireworks now is all
new and it's all exciting
I'm just trying to just have a little
bit more patience and just hang on it's
coming okay it's going I love the way
they paired these actors up for the
press junkets just because of the
relationships their characters have or
implied relationships like bran and
Littlefinger sitting together for
interviews doesn't necessarily mean that
they're going to spend a lot of time
together but they'll both be at
Winterfell together but you have people
like Davos and Melisandre that won't
meet up again until Davos and Jon Snow
go to Dragonstone everybody's been
teasing the craziest reunions all across
season 7 this is going to be one of my
favorite ones I don't think there's a
whole lot of theory crafting to be done
between brand and Littlefinger because
even though brand has all this
information that he can reveal to
everyone
Littlefinger's biggest problem is now
beerus because Varys knows everything
that Littlefinger's done
Sansa might figure out through Arya or
another character that Littlefinger
betrayed her family in Ned Stark back
during season 1 but Varys is the person
that could confirm all that
oh yeah it's his fault he's the one that
did all these things this is how he did
it the only problem with that is that
Littlefinger has sweet Robin in his
pocket which means that he has the veil
in his pocket in all their forces and
they command one of the largest standing
armies in the realm they could really
help or really hurt Daenerys his cause
because you win the North arguably you
win Santa's help and Littlefinger wants
to help Sansa so it's implied that you
would also win the veil but I love the
fact that Podrick and gray were more
sitting next to each other the man who
is no man and the man who is the biggest
man according to Littlefinger's brothel
I'm not really expecting to to them to
be on-screen together that much unless
Brienne goes to Dragonstone and she
would only go to Dragonstone
if songs I went to dragonstone and it
sounds like she's going to be staying at
Winterfell for most of the season
Samwell in the Hound is a pretty
interesting pairing to the Hound is
spending most of his time in the north
but if this does turn out to be him in
the dragon pits and that would be the
place where Samwell would meet up with
him at the end of the season because
he's spending most of his time way down
south of the Citadel really the only
other big thing that happened in the
last couple of days is they dropped a
couple new preview images one of Santa
and Littlefinger with her wearing her
new costume she's looking at him like
he's saying something that she doesn't
necessarily want to hear like he's
speaking ill of what jon snow's plans
are or whatever possible future they
might have because there have been a lot
of scenes with Jon Snow in the
Great Hall talking to all these people
about how they need to band together but
the other preview is just a much better
look at Daenerys walking up to her
throne in Dragonstone it almost looks
like the throne itself is made of
partial dragon glass like you have the
Iron Throne is made from melted-down
swords but then you have the dragon
glass throne but a lot of this mostly
looks like carved rock but if you
haven't seen in my previous videos
there's a shot of Daenerys in the caves
beneath Dragonstone there are thick
veins of dragonglass that just run amok
all over the place
so what Stannis said the dragon stone
it's littered with dragonglass it
literally runs throughout dragon stone
so it makes sense that a bunch of it
would be running through this throne
here too and it's a really great
metaphor the dragon throne is made
partially of dragonglass
and Daenerys has the Dragons one of the
greatest weapons against the White
Walkers and the army of the Dead
just another really good example of Game
of Thrones using set design to tell
story in a really elegant way well let
me know in the comments what do you
think is going on with your on and
Cersei this season and what's going to
happen is there'll be new Game of
Thrones in a couple days there's a bunch
of stuff coming up hopefully you guys
had a great 4th of July I'll say
congratulations to the latest giveaway
winner Alexander Jay please private
message me so I can get your contact
details you can click here for my Gendry
video and you can click here to rewatch
the trailer thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight